[Música]
hola buenas tardes a todos cómo están
todo bien
es un placer estar entre tantos
ingenieros que hacen cosa útil para el
país yo soy mercadólogo
algo muy útil para el país les mando
publicidad
pensé que me iban a aplaudir gracias
jean luc por mandarnos tanta publicidad
en las redes sociales no esté yo también
profesor en universidades decir que
también enseñó a chicos a mandarles
publicidad por si yo iba a fallar y este
y lo que les voy a contar me pasó en la
universidad pero no me pasó en el salón
de clases sino que me pasó en los
pasillos de la universidad me encontré
una tarde un chica solita en el pasillo
llorando entonces como un buen profesor
me acercó a ella y le pregunto qué te
pasa no mires al profesor o profesión
profis hay profes mi novio me acaba de
cortar con un mensajito
andaba así con su celular chico como
puede ser
que un niño corte a una niña por
mensajito que nos está pasando con este
asistente con nuestro celular no
entonces me pongo a pensar porque este
niño corto a esa niña con un mensajito
pues tenía miedo se le hizo fácil dijo
mejor lo pongo a míster
abstente no tengo que estar enfrentando
este problema en la vida real mejor lo
hago sin tener ningún sentimiento sin
sentir ninguna emoción
qué está pasando no se estudia de hecho
hace dos semanas salió un estudio en
francia que nos dicen de uno de cada
diez adolescentes ya cortaron a su novio
su novia dos celular por mensajito les
pregunto a ustedes alguien de ustedes se
acortó un novio una niña por celular
bien
alba hay barrios
3 me pongo a pensar pues este niño lo
que quiso es evadir su responsabilidad y
me di cuenta que este celular
este aparato nos permite valer nuestra
responsabilidad y nuestra vida real no
entonces me pongo a pensar después y qué
tal se vayan ellos juntado para cortar
pues también de la misma manera
seguramente mientras los dos hablan
estarían checando su celular es decir en
la misma vida
veo que hay unas risas de adolescentes
que el que si ya hay unos que sí se
sienten atacado ahí no seguramente
habrían agarraron su celular para que
igual para evadir el otro porque al
final qué hacemos cuando tenemos esta
seguridad de este pequeño aparato pues
evadimos el otro de hecho este fenómeno
tiene un nombre llama el footing no sé
si alguien conoce esa palabra
el fútbol ya que viene de fondo y es
nada pues no vean es el hecho de estar
usando su celular cuando estamos al
frente de otros seres humanos creo que
todos lo hicimos aquí
de hecho dejadme ver si hay unos que
están checando su celular más que
escucharme
seguramente por ahí ya veo uno
muchas gracias
el footing es algo que nos está pasando
a todos hoy en día ajustar el espacio
estar en la cena o usar su celular
aunque sea dos segundos o ver a otros
seres celular
alguien de ustedes
trabajar con millennials
sí
qué rico es cuando un niño los minions
están en junta de trabajo todos
agarrándose la radio te escucha desde
psoe por favor presten me atención
testigo que nos está pasando algo está
pasando y no nos damos cuenta y creo que
es algo grave y les voy a preguntar a
todos que es lo primero que hacen cuando
abren los ojos en la mañana
agarra el celular
qué es lo único que lo último que hacen
antes de dormir en la noche agarra el
celular
muchas gracias creo que tenemos un
problema no y no nos damos cuenta no
y este problema que es al final cuenta
este aparato nos hace que nos estamos
separando de la vida real
hay pocos estudios todavía sobre el tema
pero lo que sí es que hay psicólogos que
reciben chicos chicas adultos que tienen
problemas de depresión problema de
soledad porque porque están solamente
hablando con una máquina con un
asistente electrónico una en una
inteligencia artificial no personalmente
tenemos un problema entre parejas se
pasa con mi pareja a veces pero en
cuenta en la manera que todavía no la
salud y yo ya estoy saludando a todo el
mundo a través de las redes sociales no
seguramente hasta mi esposa la saludó a
través de facebook aunque esté dormida a
mi lado no está dormida está checando su
celular no esto es nuestro problema
entonces qué está pasando hay que
intentar ver a qué nos sirve ese celular
lo celular es un asistente maravilloso
muy bonito para empezar no nos separamos
de él después la misma chica de la
universidad unos días después merecía un
día 6 en mi celular en esencia desnuda
no siempre está con nosotros entonces
cómo funciona este celular y qué quiere
no todas las plataformas redes sociales
google todas las plataformas trabajan
con lo que llamamos un algoritmo el
organismo a primero y está hecho para
ayudarlos es decir conocernos para
ofrecernos soluciones que nos pueden
convenir no es que hacen esos algoritmos
facebook twitter google etcétera
nosotros empezar a conocer pues es
primero
conocen nuestros datos demográficos
donde nacimos si somos hombre y mujer
que la tenemos
cuál es nuestra situación sentimental si
tenemos hijos si estamos casados los
datos demográficos pero algo más porque
todos metemos en internet no no hay 30
por ciento de los casados que dicen en
facebook declaran que son solteros
por si que hay algo mejor no para que
serás las puertas no
entonces saben eso pero además saben
nuestros intereses que buscamos en
google qué tipo de periódico digo nos
gusta
cuál es nuestra orientación política
toda esta información a la va acumulando
además de dónde estamos hacia dónde
vamos cuál es nuestro historial de
desplazamientos en todo el mundo
nuestro comportamiento es decir con qué
objeto nos conectamos a qué horas nos
conectamos y toda esta información la
acumulada esos algoritmos para filtrar
la información que nos van a mandar
aunque no lo crean dicen que internet es
grande libre abierto lo que recibimos
nosotros es lo que quiere que esos
algoritmos veamos según ellos para que
porque sienten que es lo que necesitamos
de hecho hagan la prueba ustedes es muy
interesante cada muro de facebook de
cada uno es diferente todos vemos cosas
diferentes lo que encontramos en google
es diferente según cada persona
entonces me digo pues para qué tender
esos algoritmos primero si no satisface
si se supone que recibimos lo que
necesitamos pero el gran problema es que
no recibimos toda la información en
particular la que no nos gusta por eso
decimos que internet es un mundo feliz
porque nunca vamos a recibir algo que
nos disgusta es decir que al final de
cuentas este algoritmo que hace nos
encierra en nuestras actitudes nos
hacemos una especie de burbuja en lo
cual toda la información que recibimos
es la información que queremos ver y yo
quiero ver otras cosas quién está harto
de su muro de youtube
o sea en youtube ya vemos exactamente lo
mismo se están repitiendo quiero ver
otras cosas en el mundo pobre algoritmo
no es porque este algoritmo no solamente
para disque
cumplir nuestras necesidades pero es
también para vendernos algo no es mi
trabajo o sea yo puedo ubicar los que
tienen entre 24 años hasta 32 que son
mujeres solteras que tienen como interés
la librería los libros etcétera para
mandarles anuncios gracias a esa
segmentación esto es los que nos quieren
las marcas y las plataformas que
desarrollan esos sistemas de sus
algoritmos y que quieren en particular
que no dejes de ver tu celular si bien
en los años 40 ya había espacios
publicitarios en nuestros hogares
ahorita los espacios publicitarios están
a menos de 50 centímetros todo el tiempo
conmigo no gracias facebook google
twitter no
porque no dinero a través de ellos
por eso el gran objetivo de esas
compañías que es es que no dejemos de
ver la pantalla para poder consumir más
y más publicidad por eso a cada ratones
recibimos notificaciones que es por
favor no me olvides de mi pantalla otra
vez para ver un espacio publicitario
esto es los que nos piden sí
entonces está corriendo los tamagotchis
pero así funciona nos necesitamos de
comer lo cuidamos lo mandamos al baño
siempre lo vemos como un amigo que
tenemos que atender sí
entonces ante este fenómeno que pudimos
hacer
pues creo que tenemos uno reflexionar
preguntarnos si estamos adictos a este
pequeño aparato ocho horas por día
utilizamos el celular ocho horas por día
creo que nos podríamos calmarlo hay algo
que se llama auto-control este
autocontrol no lo tenemos con el celular
se están riendo porque creo que hay unos
enfermos hay histéricos
el autocontrol que es paso en la calle
ve un helado mi primera reacción es lo
quiero comer pero reflexionó llegó y la
dieta que yo tengo que a otro
controlarme un poco más
y al final no vamos a comer ese helado
esto es lo que tenemos que hacer con
celular tener autocontrol no y saber que
tenemos derecho a la desconexión quién
de ustedes usa whatsapp en el trabajo
una gran mayoría quien está harto de
whatsapp
los mismos no allí estamos separamos un
poco la vida pública y la vida privada a
los domingos en la tarde estoy con mi
hijo y me están checando me están
mandando una notificación de la chamba
porque no puedo yo solamente trabajar
ocho horas por día porque ya no
otra cosa muy importante es entender
cómo funciona la tecnología la pregunta
es la tecnología nos domina y nosotros
dominamos la tecnología es decir cuando
se inventó la máquina de escribir que
nos dio la máquina de escribir
sino tener una hoja mucho más limpia y
mucho más visible dos pueden escribir
mucho más rápido están de acuerdo
siempre y cuando yo la uso no solamente
con un dedo porque si usó una máquina de
escribir con un dedo al final de cuenta
escribo mucho más lento que si escribo a
mano no de hecho les pregunto a todos
hace mucho que no escriben con una pluma
sobre un papel
y entender lo intenté lo van a ver que
tienen una muy bonita escritura el día
de hoy
se nos está olvidando es decir que
olvidamos unas
unas cualidades olvidamos unas funciones
que teníamos y tenemos que ir entendió
entendiendo otras y esto es algo muy
importante porque cuando hablamos del
celular no hablamos de un martillo o sea
yo para usar un martillo no necesito
tener una licenciatura no estoy estudiar
para saber usar un martillo pero un
celular sí porque primero necesito saber
cómo funciona la tecnología es decir
cómo funcionan las diferentes
aplicaciones que usamos de hecho les
pregunto a todos
puede montar la mano una persona que si
leyó los términos de uso de facebook
no veo ninguno creo que necesitan
acercarse un poco más a la tecnología
para entender cómo funcionan estos
algoritmos y que nos proponen tres
primeros tenemos que saber cómo funciona
es más no sé si les pasa estar con una
persona que dice ah yo no entiendo nada
al celular por favor expliquen ley es
una lucha entre la máquina y nosotros
tenemos que ser solidarios no 211 esos
algoritmos lo que necesitamos es saber
cómo
buscar información alguien de ustedes no
usa google
alguien de ustedes usa otro navegador
que google otro buscador
pues a todos esos en google gracias
vivir
pues aprendan que es un fake news cómo
puedo yo segmentar la operación cómo
puedo filtrar la información para
después hacer la mía es decir que esas
habilidades cognitivas son
indispensables para usar este aparato
que no es un objeto es un aparato que de
aprendizaje sí pero tiene algo extraño
o sea cuando nosotros papás padres de
familia compramos una computadora en
nuestro niño lo hicimos es para el bien
de su educación estamos de acuerdo
pero cuando compramos un celular les
estamos diciendo lo mismo no va a ser un
infierno más bien va a estar tranquilo y
no nos va a molestar durante el día
la tercera habilidad que tenemos que
tener para poder controlar ello
es el poder comunicarnos cómo
comunicarse con un mensajito con una
persona que no está frente de mí cómo
puedo yo comunicarme con una máquina a
un chat automatizado le tengo que decir
gracias o le puedo gritar así le puedo
gritar o le tengo que hablar bien
entonces tenemos que tener habilidades
tecnológicas habilidades cognitivas y
habilidades comunicacionales para poder
usar el señalamiento y ahorita antes de
cerrar les pregunto a todos quién de
ustedes cree que es adicto al celular
y entonces ya están ya parece una sesión
de alcohólicos anónimos aquí bienvenidos
para compartir su experiencia les voy a
pillar a todos los que tienen celular
que lo levanten por favor
que no levanten de estar ok ahorita les
voy a pedir que lo apaguen por favor les
voy dar unos segundos por favor apaguen
su celular no tengan miedo
se sentirán solos un rato ya están todos
apagados
apaguen el pulsador si veo que está más
tranquilo ok
sobre está les retó por favor intenten
no encenderlo durante las 24 horas
sé que no sabrán dónde está sus hijos
ellos van a estar felices sé que no van
a saber dónde está su pareja no sabrán
los chismes de sus amigos se les puede
ir unos cumpleaños el día de mañana
al presión van a sentir un poco de
angustia van a tener como las ganas de
agarrarlo otra vez de prenderlo de tener
hoy tengo notificaciones que atenderlo
pero van a ver que con un poco de horas
mañana en la mañana se van a sentir
felices les aconsejo hoy en un café
comprar un periódico impreso un libro
impreso se acuerdan los libros impresos
los periódicos
agarra no comencé en la cafetería y van
a ver que poco a poco se van a sentir
felices porque porque ya están dominando
la tecnología
muchas gracias a todos muchas gracias a
gabriel por el segmento fantástico
[Aplausos]
[Música]